[Music]  this is nidus the adaptive the Scourge  he mutates like an epidemic sweeping  through the battlefield verily  structures forth a way of infestation  with each enemy afflicted or infestation  begins to stack and mutate saving  stacked mutations will multiply its  destructive force while refunding a  portion of its casting cost larva spawns  an infested pod that erupts with  tendrils latching on to nearby enemies  and holding them down parasitic link  creates a temporary subió cyst with your  target with allies you both get a boost  of strength and they'll increase  whereas enemies will receive a  percentage of damage inflicted upon  nidus put a pox upon their house 10 Oh  ravenous sets forth gluttonous maggots  that swarm nearby enemies feasting until  they burst with infestation the maggots  benefit from mutation and each enemy  consumed adds to the mutation stack  nidus is a deadly plague for which there  is no cure you must control the strange  disease